hello and welcome to week five of the
Boer report fantasy football show
brought to you by State Farm my name is
Adam Levitan joined once again by Mark
danen bring we are from establish the
run.com going to hang out for the next
30 minutes here today talking who to
start this week on your teams Mark how's
it going
today it's going great excited for week
five you know officially into October
here and it's it's feeling like football
season officially now that we're a month
in so always good talk football with you
Adam pump to be here I know that it's
the middle of football season because I
have not been outside in roughly three
months you guys can see my pale
disgusting face right here before we get
into some of the starts here today that
we like let's take a couple questions
from chat C Davis says are we starting
jir Gibbs against Carolina this week I'd
say two things on this Mark first you
can run the I mean you can do anything
you want on Carolina they have major
problems defensively so that's a good
thing for jir Gibbs on the other side
Lions have won by riding David
Montgomery very very hard and they have
played good offense by riding Dave
Montgomery very very hard I don't see
much motivation for them to change the
split there mark what do you think about
starting jir Gibbs this
week yeah I think if you're starting
Gibbs you're banking on some pass game
work coming in this game against
Carolina we've seen in in the healthy
games with David Montgomery that jir
Gibbs hasn't gotten more than eight
rushing attempts and and last week David
Montgomery got 32 attempts to his eight
so uh the lions are heavy home favorites
here I I do like you know playing Gibbs
if if you don't have many other options
especially in in more PPR leagues but in
half PPR and and standard leagues um
there might be some better options out
there because again he's not going to
get all that much rushing work with
Montgomery fully healthy yeah I mean
guys like Damien Pierce guys like uh
Julio mgin if javante Williams doesn't
play CLE Herbert they might actually be
better in half PPR for this spot than
jir Gibbs and it pains me to say that
but I think you're going to need some
serious efficiency like Mark said on the
pass catching from jir Gibbs Colton says
are we starting DJ Moore tonight appr
pressing question here from Colton
kickoff is coming up here in a few hours
what do you think about the spot for DJ
Moore tonight Mark against the
commanders I think it's a decent spot
after week one where DJ Moore only got
two targets he's had at least a 25%
Target share in every game with 22
targets over the last three weeks so you
know the Bears have certainly made him
the focal point of the offense of the
passing offense you know at least after
their offseason trade so uh we've seen
this Washington secondary get burned a
little bit by The Eagles last week I do
think DJ Moore is startable tonight you
know I just say I'm not sold on Justin
Fields is suddenly going to start
shredding just because he did it against
what could go down as one of the worst
defenses of all time in
the Broncos so I'm a little bit
skeptical on DJ Moore like if you had
Tyler Boyd if T Higgins doesn't play if
you had Z flowers even like Adam thielen
I think I feel a little bit better about
than DJ Moore right now which is
sickening to say all right here's what
we're gonna do
today we are going to talk about six
players that we think are pretty good
starts this week some of them got off to
bad starts some of them got off to good
starts some of them just have good
matchups the idea though and we didn't
prep this ahead of time our good friends
at Bleacher Report behind the scenes are
going to surprise us with some players
around the guy we're going to say and
say whether we'd start or sit them we're
calling it The
Gauntlet all right bear with us this is
our first time going through the
gauntlet not sure exactly what to expect
here the first one for me and this is a
guy that I know people are down on I
understand that it's been a struggle to
start this season season Jaylen wad to
me is still a very important piece of a
very concentrated offense They Don't
Really throw a wide receiver three They
Don't Really throw very much to tight
end running back Target rates have
gotten better lately but still not sure
that that's sticky it's time to get
Jaylen wad going and jayen Wadd going in
a big way here I think a match up
against the Giants is a fine place for
that to start so I hope people weren't
Panic dumping Jaylen wad I think it's
going to be okay on him starting with
this week now I'm not sure exactly
what's going to happen now I believe
that I'm about to go through the
gauntlet on Jaylen Wadd so stay
tuned ah let me see the first I need to
say the magic word let me see the first
receiver in the gauntlet ah DJ Moore yes
great one because I just talked about DJ
Moore easy no-brainer for me Jaylen Wadd
over DJ Moore quarterback play game enir
IR I think will be better here against
the Giants and just raw Talon I actually
think that Jaylen wad is a better player
than DJ Moore so no problem there Jaylen
wad over DJ more for me how
about the next guy in The
Gauntlet oh DeAndre Hopkins come on this
guy is is withered withered DeAndre
Hopkins we actually have DeAndre Hopkins
projected for more points than Jaylen
waddle this week I have
concerns that at this point IND Deandre
Hopkins career he's just
like he's going to earn targets but he's
a contested catch guy and like it's
really hard to make big plays in that
setup when your quarterback is Ryan
tanah and in games that they win like di
Henry is gonna touch the ball 25 times
when they lose it'll look better for
DeAndre Hopkins I'm going against our
projection we have DeAndre Hopkins for
0.8 more than Jaylen wad I'm going
against it and I'll stick with Jaylen
wad there give me one more final end
boss in the The Gauntlet
oh Christian Kirk back-to-back London
Games for the uh Jaguars I believe here
yeah I'm still going Wadd you know you
guys are trying to get me off of Jaylen
Wadd you're not going to do it the
pendulum I think is going to swing back
at some point to Calvin Ridley in the
Target share tree for the Jaguars and I
would say that um shifting away from
Kirk and more Ridley as soon as this
week I don't think is a crazy take to
have so still waddle for me there all
three waddle for me all
right go ahead Mark with your first
streaming your first start of the week
yeah I think a must start this week for
me at the running back position is
Isaiah Pacho of the Chiefs um you know
they they get the Vikings and they're in
the highest total game of the weekend
and we've seen Pacho you know the Chiefs
played the Bears in in week three didn't
really get a full peo workload but in
week four he really separated from Clyde
Edwards Air played over 60% of the snaps
against the Jets ripped off over 100
rushing yards and he's been involved in
the passing game so you know the Chiefs
have the second highest team total of
the week expecting them to score a lot
of points and oftentimes that means you
know running back Rush attempts near the
goal line and I like Isaiah Pacho a lot
in this matchup so he's a must start for
me you know more in the rb2 range not
necessarily a locked in rb1 but excited
to see who the gauntlet throws at us
here to pair against Isaiah
Pacho oh mil Sanders yeah this is
definitely an Isaiah Peko over my
sanders for me the Panthers are on the
road against Detroit you know my sanders
is dealing with a groin injury that saw
him split snaps almost evenly with chuba
hubard last week he's still on the
injury report Lions been really strong
against the run so far this year so
pretty easily Isaiah Peko for me in that
one let's go to the next
guy Madison yeah this is um you know
counterparts in the same game and
surprisingly I actually think I feel a
little bit better about Isaiah Paco's
role in this one with Cam Acres he'll be
playing in a second game behind
Alexander Madison for the Vikings could
potentially siphon off some touches
there and uh you know the Chiefs are
going in as decent favorites in this one
so expecting a little bit more usage for
Pacho so I I'll lean Pacho there over
Madison there in that same game so final
boss time for PCO here Brian Robinson
wow I was thinking this might be a name
that was going to come up as final boss
because it's a it's an absolutely
awesome matchup for Brian Robinson
tonight against the Bears this is man
this this is pretty pretty tough for me
I think I would probably have to side
with Robinson here just because you know
I'm expecting Washington to really play
with a lead at home against the Bears on
Thursday night uh you know I think our
our touch projection for Robinson is
probably five six seven touches higher
just with how much he's used in the
rushing game against Kansas City again
Kansas City you know is more of a pass
heavy team so I think Robinson for more
touches there so I think Peko loses in
the final round to to Brian Robinson
yeah easy Brian Robinson for me there I
think people underestimate how good
Brian Robinson has been and how this
team wants to use Brian Robinson in the
right game Flow and I expect him to have
the right game Flow tonight I I like
Brian Robinson actually uh a lot tonight
and just in general all
right let's go to my next one here it's
going to be David
Montgomery I repeat David Montgomery now
I just talked about the Gibbs stuff I
mean you know I don't see why they
changeed David Montgomery had 32 carries
last week Gibbs had eight and Montgomery
ran two more routes than Gibbs I mean
the way that Montgomery's playing right
now and the way that they've been
winning just doesn't make me think that
they're going to take their foot off the
gas with him and now you got a home home
game against the Panthers this team is
also the most run-heavy team in the Red
Zone in the entire NFL by a wide margin
that's how you get 17 Jamal Williams
rushing touchdowns last year Dave
Montgomery already has five rushing
touchdowns in three games in a home game
where they've been so good have the
Lions expecting a lot of touchdown and
Red Zone opportunities for the Lions
here so I think a really really good
spot for David Montgomery I hope the
gauntlet has some good ones here because
there are not many guys this week that I
would play o David Montgomery oh my God
guys James Conor is like 40 years old I
mean I understand that I'm 41 but but
James Connor is just as withered as I am
we're also seeing this guy that nobody's
ever heard of including me ail de
Marcado get some pass down work which is
a threat to James Conor's every down
roll is me I don't think this one is
particularly close I understand Josh dos
has played well but I just don't think
Arizona's offense is going to be able to
sustain that Dave Montgomery easily give
me another
one Travis ATN yeah I I think Travis
etan's usage has actually been better
than people think I I was worried about
Travis etn on Pass Downs worried about
him at the goal line they drafted tank
bsby none of that has come to fruition
Travis etn has played and played a ton I
think it's close on this one but still
think David Montgomery here for me I'm a
long time Dave Montgomery stand my bags
are fully packed on Dave Montgomery in
the season long last one here DeAndre
Swift yeah we got a really good look at
Eagles backfield last week because they
were in a close game and all their
running backs were healthy and so what
we saw was Rashad Penny healthy scratch
Boston Scott played zero offensive snaps
it was all Swift and then gainwell was
the change of pace guy that said Jaylen
Herz steals so much they're tush pushing
from the two yard line now I mean they
they they are getting out of control
with the tush push I saw a three- yard
tush push or maybe it was like two and a
half yard tush push and so in order for
DeAndre Swift to score I feel like it's
got to be from the five yard line or the
four yard line otherwise it's going to
be Jaylen Hertz tush push more touchdown
Equity I think for David Montgomery in
this spot so I will stick with him but
yeah etn and Swift are certainly both
really really strong plays I just really
like Dave Montgomery this
week all right
let's go now to you know what let's jump
into the fantasy bundles presented by
our friends at State Farm where building
your home in auto insurance is just
another way to save with the personal
price plan and this is a part of the
show where we talk about some Stacks
that we like Mark anybody out there
playing DFS that is our favorite form or
at least my favorite form of fantasy and
when you're playing tournament stacking
is very very very important obviously if
we think Sam Howell has a good game game
well Terry mcclaren's probably going to
have a good game as well tonight Mark
what do you think about McClaren who by
the way McClaren has seen his Target
share rise pretty sharply over the last
few
weeks yeah I love this Duo tonight you
know with especially with how I'll hit
on how first because this is an
interesting bye I think for season long
you know we have the Browns on the buy
so deshun Watson not available the
Chargers are on byy Justin Herbert's not
available um we've also have Seattle on
a buy Gino Smith not available so I
think people are looking for quarterback
streamers and I think Sam Hal is at the
top of the list when we look at
streaming options this week the Bears
have been second allowing fantasy points
to opposing QBs you know only behind uh
the Broncos there have just been
historically bad so the Bears in any
other season would be you know arguably
the worst defense against passers thus
far they're also without Jaylen Johnson
and Eddie Jackson and their secondary
who are arguably their two best
defensive players so I think the setup
here is really nice for Hal and you
mentioned mclen had a higher Target
share in the last three weeks than Johan
doson and you know just a reminder that
mclen came into the season nursing a
turf toe injury and has been off the
injury report the last few weeks he's
seemingly 100% and uh his average at the
Target is is a bit deeper than doson so
I think you know even given the same
amount of targets we can expect McLaren
to have a better fantasy outing than
doson all things equal
otherwise
okay let's go to the
Dolphins who Tyreek kale underwhelmed in
Buffalo last week now he gets this
Giants team Tua and Tyreek Hill strikes
me as a very strong sack that is going
to be a chalky one whereas people are
way less uh likely to click on Jaylen
Wadd but yeah I think people probably
don't think the Giants are like some
slam dunk spot I think the Giants are a
pretty good spot for this Duo here Mark
what do you think about Tua and Tyreek
this week definitely I love this as as a
little bounceback spot for Miami after
you know getting beat on the road in
Buffalo they're back at home um we've
seen Tyreek have a 30% Target share in
every game except that week four game
against Buffalo so I do think he'll
remain you know the wide receiver one
here clearly I I do like Wadd this week
but just the just the role for Ty Tyreek
in this offense with Mike McDaniel
scheming it up to a looking at him for
first reads most of the time there's
just hard to find many better fantasy
wide receivers than Tyreek Hill and I I
agree with you it's a it's a pretty
solid matchup at home against the Giants
third bundle to talk about is Lamar
Jackson and Z flowers this one comes
against Pittsburgh we have these images
in our head of the Steel Curtain
defense CJ strad shredded them last week
as did Nico Collins what do you think
about this spot for Lamar and
Z yeah the the Steelers surprisingly
have have allowed the second most
fantasy points per game to opposing wide
receivers thus far so I do think it is a
better matchup then like you mentioned
people might Envision just off the top
of their head and we've seen Z flowers
get the most targets among wide
receivers in three out of the four games
for Baltimore um you know again Mark
Andrews is probably the number one
Target in this offense but when it goes
to the wide receiver room Z flowers is
clearly on top there Rashad baitman and
Odell Beckham Jr are both on the injury
report it looks like they're trending
towards playe but they might be limited
in some fashion so I still like leaning
into the into the Z flowers rookie hype
train here
yeah and I mean Ravens had trouble
running the ball and you know obviously
they don't have JK Dobbins like they
just get these quick low passes to Z
flowers especially in PPR leagues I like
Z more H fourth bundle is Jaylen Herz
and AJ Brown now Rams defense has played
better than I think anyone thought that
they would this year they do not have a
lot of names on defense they do not have
a lot of talent outside I think of Aaron
Donald however they played some pretty
good ball Jaylen Herz and AJ Brown
though obviously two of the best players
in the league at their respective
position what do you think about the
spot for these
guys yeah I I just love this game
environment it's the second highest
total game on the week uh Pat thorman of
established the run right a snaps and
Pace column each week highlighting games
that are likely to have a lot of play
volume and in fantasy we want to Target
play volume and potential touchdowns and
I think you know AJ Brown is just kind
of the perfect combination there in this
game so far this season he has 14 more
targets than devont Smith uh we've seen
that you know be close to even over the
last couple years with with both of them
in the lineup but I do think AJ Brown is
the preferred Target here and um you
know I just I just want to keep riding
this hot hot train AJ Brown is fifth in
the NFL and targets and six and
receiving yards so just you know all
things all things go for him and I think
it's going to continue again this
week I will say there is some squeaky
wheel stuff around Dallas SCD Devonte
Smith you know everybody's always
complaining at some at some point in
time they want the ball more so is what
it is AJ Brown was just complaining not
too long ago either last bundle Jordan
love and chrisan Watson they faced the
Las Vegas Raiders Jordan love I think
played last Thursday night against the
Lions that was the kind of game that I
think people were worried that he was
going to play this year where he's going
to be aggressive he's goingon to throw
the ball down the field but there's
going to be a lot of mistakes we did see
Christian Watson Return To Play about
half of the routes did catch a touchdown
long layoff here Mark I think matters I
mean 11 days get Christian Watson fully
healthy what do you think about this
one definitely that that's the bet here
for me and it gives the coaching staff
you know a full 10 11 days to game plan
for their next opponent whereas last
Thursday night even though it was a
divisional opponent against the Lions
you know they really only have about
three days to turn that around and
develop a game plan so I do think
Christian Watson will be full go likely
lead wide receivers and snaps and routes
or at least be close you know up close
to Romeo dobs and uh We've we've
mentioned a few times you know
throughout the year that Jordan love
leads the NFL and averages at the Target
and that's really where Christian Watson
wins is down the field explosive plays
and the Raiders defense not very
talented at this point so I I do like
betting on this tandem with 10 days to
prepare and in Watson hopefully at full
strength for this
one all right let's get back to the
gauntlet here uh by the way to be clear
the good Folks at Bleacher Report we
have no idea what's coming uh in The
Gauntlet here we all we did was say
names and so we're getting surprised
here by the Players let's put Christian
Watson Into The Gauntlet Mark I mean we
just talked about him go ahead and put
Christian Watson at The Gauntlet for you
marks up on
Watson yeah perfect timing I I just kind
of G gave my you know case for why I
think it's going to be a breakout week
for him and and week five obviously it's
been very frustrating for Fantasy
managers out the first three games uh
luckily bailed out a little bit by a
touchdown in week four against the Lions
otherwise it would have been a
disappointing performance but again love
this matchup think he's going to be full
go so excited to see toss him in the
gauntlet and and see who we're comparing
him against this
week oh a teammate right off the bat oh
man Romeo dobs and you know dobs we
thought would be a little bit more
impacted last Thursday with with both
Aaron Jones and Watson coming back he
did catch nine balls for 95 yards and
well I think you know you can maybe make
a case that Romeo dos is going to see
more targets I I think the ones that
Christian Wat sees are going to be more
downfield Christian Watson a much more
explosive player you know highly touted
Prospect um so I I I lean Watson there
just off
explosiveness and upside for
sure all
right Michael Thomas wow this one so the
the Saints are on the road against the
Patriots I believe and you know tough
showing from Derek Carr last week as he
battles this AC joint spraining in his
shoulder we saw alvan Kamar come back
and immediately have 14 targets so I
think you know moving forward we can
kind of project fewer wide receiver
targets here for the Saints and I think
that does trickle down to Michael Thomas
now that he's the wide receiver too
Chris alve is the alpha in that offense
so just given the game environment
Christian Watson likely being the wide
receiver one in Green Bay and Thomas the
wide receiver two in New Orleans I'm
gonna lean Watson
there now onto the final boss stage and
uh oh same game same game competitor
here and jacobe Myers and the the
Raiders are interesting just because um
you know their targetry has been so
condensed Devonte Adams jacobe Myers and
Josh Jacobs are are really the only
players on the Raiders seeing targets
right now so you can see that you know
the projections a bit higher for jacobe
Myers and I think that's probably right
just because the volume is is probably
safer um for him I do think here
Christian Watson probably has a wider
range of outcomes and and likely a
higher ceiling so I think in season long
you know we're looking for more weeks
that'll or performances that are going
to win us the week right like 25 points
from Christian Watson is is a lot more
valuable than let's say 14 from from
jacobe Meers so uh it's close for me but
I'm gonna lean Watson here and and hope
that this is his Breakout game in the
season all
right Christian Watson rolls all
right number five will go Michael pit
Jr I
mean Anthony Richardson struggled in the
first half but they were still playing
very fast they were still playing
relatively throw Centric first down
throw rate remains really good Pace
remains really good now obviously anthon
rich is not the best thrower in the NFL
the most accurate thrower in the NFL
however he has shown major affinity for
Michael Pitman let's see what the
gauntlet brings here for Mr P Pitman oh
and by the way the uh Colts are hosting
at home in the Dome the Tennessee Titans
this week and by the way the Tennessee
Titans have arguably actually maybe
inarguably well fine I'll say arguably
the biggest pass funnel in the NFL in
other words they're very good against
the run and very good and very bad
against the pass okay Pitman verse Mr
Pickins here yeah my my pickings takes I
just have not been on George Pickins
like everybody else has for a while the
main reason is that Matt Canada strikes
me as adult who can't figure out how to
use his players in an optimal way and he
starts sending George Pickins on these
routes that are just like let's run up
the sideline we're gonna Chuck it deep
and we're gonna pray that George Pickins
comes down with it and maybe that's fine
Strat you know maybe that's fine
strategy like George Pickins can do
things like that it's just really hard
to rely on that I think floor way higher
on Michael Pitman here I do think Kenny
picket will be back from the knee injury
but difference between Kenny picket and
Mitchell trabis is like almost nothing
in my opinion at this point let's go to
Z flowers yeah we talked about Z flowers
a couple times here I do think that
extension of Run game stuff is really
good for Z
flowers ah this is a really really close
one I I think I would go Pitman as the
better bet for a touchdown here but
super super close if you look at our
projections we actually have Pitman and
Z flowers 1.2 points apart and half PPR
in favor of Pitman so I'll stick with
the projection there and go Pitman again
Dome Tennessee is one of the best spots
that Michael Pitman will have all
year yes I know this guy's named
Hollywood Maris Brown I don't know if
you guys know it's actually fake
Hollywood he's from Hollywood Florida
not Hollywood California just want to
just want to make that clear there for
the people yeah um I think that this
game environment for Maris Brown is
actually going to be
pretty interesting here against the
Bengals I mean we've seen the Bengals
struggle so so so badly on offense I
think Josh dos played way
better than I anyone including myself
thought that he could there's so few
guys to throw to in Arizona think I'm
going to capitulate to The Gauntlet here
I'm going to go with fake Hollywood
Maris
Brown all right let's keep it moving
here last one is marks it is Josh Jacobs
J Mark go ahead on Josh
Jacobs the role for Josh Jacobs has just
been incredible this season I mentioned
you know I'm talking about Jobe Myers
earlier that the this Vegas offense is
just extremely concentrated on a few
players and and we love that for Fantasy
right now Josh Jacobs has handled 62 of
66 running back carries that that didn't
come in garbage time he has 25 targets
that leads all NFL running back and then
he gets a matchup with the Packers which
you know we just saw David Montgomery
destroy last Thursday night the Packers
are seeding the uh ton of fantasy points
to running backs have allowed the most
catches to opposing running backs thus
far so I think it's you know dream dream
matchup for Josh Jacobs and in the
workload has been there so I'm
interested to see who the gaunlet throw
us at us because there are very very few
running backs that I'm willing to to
start over Josh Jacobs this week yeah
Kiren Williams I mean he's had one of
the best roles of any NFL running back
early on and we we did see it scaled
back a little bit just percentage wise
against the Colts but the Rams have been
running a ton of plays I mean Kiren got
at least you know over 20 carries over
100 yards rushing and two two touchdowns
last week uh but you know when when
coming at Josh Jacobs again there's
there's there's very limited names so I
I still lean Josh Jacobs here I think
you know talent-wise he's a step up from
Kiren Williams and just great game
environments and matchup for for Josh
Jacobs whereas Kiren Williams is going
against the Eagles in that vaunted
defensive line I I could see some
inefficiency from K oh Derk Henry this
one's interesting because they're on the
road against Indianapolis and in a dome
this one kind of comes down to whether
we think the Titans are going to be able
to play from ahead just because if
they're playing from behind then you
know we see a lot more Taj Spears and
with that I think there's a lot wider
range of outcomes for Derrik Henry and
uh so give me Josh Jacobs in this one
too I I think you know the floor and
ceiling is is probably
as high or higher on Jacobs than
Henry Bean
W so we have seen the the Falcons lean
on bejon a little bit more in recent
weeks you know I think the I think
Arthur Smith and the Falcons are
realizing just how much more talented
beon is compared to Tyler alir in that
backfield and so they're giving him a
few more touches um you know it's a not
as great of a matchup I don't think as
Josh Jacobs but you know certainly when
we compare like rushing role and
receiving role beon is is one of the few
backs in the NFL that that does compare
with Jacobs on both of those so I do
think Jacobs fall short here to beon and
in the final boss matchup but I mean man
both both great starts absolutely but
I'm gonna side bejon over Josh Jacobs on
that one yeah I mean bejan's pass game
role is so outrageous I mean he has like
usage equal to a mid-range tight Ender
mid-range wide receiver in the past game
a lot of weeks okay
uh just to recap our guys we like to
start this week Jaylen wad nice bounce
back spot get him going is Peko I
thought ran awesome last week Dave
Montgomery is just such a good bet for a
touchdown come Sunday Christian Watson
full health hopefully here for matchup
with the Raiders Michael Pitman one of
the best possible matchups home against
Tennessee and Josh Jacobs massive
massive role for Josh Jacobs got to a
few questions here before we get out of
here first one from Adam great name he
says Debo this week or Christian Watson
Mark you have a take there on
Debo or Christian Watson massive game
for the 49ers this Sunday night against
the
Cowboys yeah I think uh you know if both
were all all things even I would start
Debo here despite you know my optimism
on Christian Watson I will say um Debo
was you know on the injury report all
last week weren't sure if he was going
to play and uh when they they were at
home against the Cardinals so it's a bit
different than a matchup against the
Cowboys like I do think Debo will
probably push it a lot more but I mean
he had six rushing yards last week and
and that was it so you know I would
monitor the injury report the I believe
the the 49ers game is Sunday night and
then Christian Watson is Monday Night
Football so if we you know if Debo
doesn't look to be 100% I would probably
lean Watson there but if Debo gets a
full practice in by Friday I would I
would look at that take a look at that
injury report and if if he's full
practice by Friday lean Debo there yeah
I think Debo man I mean such a big game
for the 49ers like give Debo an
injection get him going you know like
it's such a massive game I I I think
Debo on that one next question from my
says which scrub should I start alir or
Sanders I mean listen meern this is the
running back position buddy everybody is
dust and that's why hopefully during
draft season you did not burn a lot of
picks at the running back position until
much later when you could have gotten
Dave Montgomery James Cook Brian
Robinson but that's a story for next
August hopefully you guys will check us
out then for Strat there but yeah alir
or my sanders I MIL Sanders role is just
so much better I don't think that's a
particularly close one Mark I understand
mil Sanders dealing with a groin injury
but I think Miles Sanders pretty easily
there from martial says Nico Collins or
Aman raah St Brown now Aman ra is
dealing with a couple injuries Tow and
oblique abdomen right now doesn't seem
great on him Nico is coming off of a
massive game what do you think about
that one Nico or
arsb yeah I think the only reason this
would be close is if if amanra was you
know really hurt going into the game but
I mean St Brown has been a locked in
wide receiver one the last couple years
again he's had over nine Targets in 20
of his last 26 games and while niik
Collins has had two blowup games you
know out of the first four weeks I I
still think you got to go Aman ra here
yeah I mean if am manra is active for an
NFL football game and I have him on my
team I'm playing him like I'm playing
him I mean yeah let's not make that one
too complicated from Ryan he says tank
Dell or DeAndre Hopkins this week tank
Dell or DeAndre Hopkins one interesting
note on tank Dell AJ Terrell you know
very good NFL quarterback one of the few
NFL quarterbacks that actually Shadows
Aon maybe this week he's on Nico Collins
which should open up a little bit more
targets and maybe production for tank
Dell we don't like to read too much in
that stuff I think it's super noisy but
at least worth noting there mark any
thoughts on tank Dell versus DeAndre
Hopkins this
week Adan Hopkins here it's you know
they're they're playing in a dome at the
Colts the Colts have been pretty
friendly to opposing wide receivers in
the bottom 10 in points allowed this
year so uh you know and we've seen just
that Titans passing attack like DeAndre
Hopkins has been the target hog there it
looks like trayon Burks could miss
another week I think when you just look
at the situations like DeAndre Hopkins
much much more likely to get 10 or 12
Targets in this game than tank Dell so
I'll go with Hopkins all right JR says
Justin Fields tonight or CJ Stroud on
Sunday Justin Fields tonight or CJ
Stroud on Sunday that's an interesting
one Mark again I said that I don't buy
what jayen Justin fields did last week
however just the fact that he can do
that with his arm you know be really
accurate throw for four touchdowns and
we know he can run for 100 yards in a
game that would make me lean Fields here
what do you think straight up fields or
Stroud yeah I just think the upside is
higher with Fields here and again we
kind of want those potential 30o weeks
from our quarterbacks in in season long
and give us a huge Advantage where I
think Stroud is you know might have a
better floor than Fields all things all
things considered but the the ceiling on
fields is much better so I'll lean
fields on this on that one all right
last question we're going to do here
today comes from Steph says James Cook
or Kiren Williams this week see this is
what I'm talking about running back man
this is all you need you have James Cook
and kir on your team you're you're
you're dancing at the running back
position we need to stop blowing picks
on cam acres and my Sanders and Damen
pier and all this nonsense anyways
anyways I digress Mark what do you think
about that one straight up at the
running back
position I think it's pretty close just
given the matchup with the Rams against
the Eagles in a PPR League I would lean
Kiren for sure I just think his his role
you know gives him such an elite floor
if it's half PPR standard I think James
Cook probably has a little bit better
shot at a touchdown this week so I I
lean that way depending on scoring
format I know that's a little Nuance so
apologies there if that doesn't help too
much all right that is going to do it
for the illustrious week five Bleacher
Report fy's football show can always
check out me and Mark's Work at
establish the run.com
follow us on Twitter mark dank Adam
Levitan and of course I'm sure you are
but be sure you're following our good
friends at Bleacher Report we'll be back
next week assuming they'll have us back
for another show Good Luck this week go
out there win all your games for Mark
for area behind the scenes at Bleacher
Report and State Farm I am Adam good
luck
everybody